هبوب بسرعه لمساعده الضحايا استجابه غير
عاديه من سكان لندن بمختلف انتماءاتهما
الدينيه والعرقيه لجمع المواد اللازمه من
بطانيات وحفاضات الاطفال والملابس الشتويه
ومستلزمات التنظيف والادويه لضحايا
الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا
من المدهشي رؤيه هذا الكم الهائل من
المساعدات رغمات تكلفه المعيشه المرتفعه
في البلاد جميع من شاهد اضرار الزلزال في
تركيا وسوريا يريد ان يتبرع حسب امكانيه
الماديه او حتى بوقته لمساعده هؤلاء
المتطوعين
اطنان من مواد الاغاثه سلمها متبرعون الى
الجمعيه التركيه البريطانيه من بينها اكثر
من 200 جهاز التدفئه هؤلاء المتطوعون
يعملون على مدار الساعه لفرز كافه انواع
المساعدات وتقسيمها لتسهيل عمليه التوزيع
في وقت لاحق على المتضررين من الزلزال
ما نحتاج اليه بدرجه الاولى هو التوعيه
بالكارثه واشراك الناس اخبارها قد لا
تستطيع المساعده لكن يمكنك ان تعرف شخصا
يرغب في ذلك نحن حاليا بحاجه الى خيم لان
الناس هناك بلا ماوى
الناس يموتون من الجوع والبرد والحكومه
التركيه لم تقدم المساعده الكافيه وقريه
النورهاق تحديدا حيث يقطن جدي لم نسمع
منهما منذ ثلاثه ايام ولا ادري ان كان على
قيد الحياه او في عدد الاموات
هازال متطوعه تجهل مصير جديها اللذين كان
يعيشان في قريه دمرها الزلزال
هناك الكثير من الطلبه من الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا يساعدوننا بشكل كبير الى
جانب الجاليات التركيه بما فيها جامعه
سواس منذ اليوم الاول بجمع تبرعات مختلفه
من ملابس ومستلزمات ضروريه
مراكز عده فتحت ابوابها لاستقبال التبرعات
العينيه فيما تعمل جمعيات اخرى على جمع
التبرعات الماليه ومنها لجه الطوارئ
الكوارث في بريطانيا التي اطلقت نداء
لمساعده مئات الاف المتضررين من الزلازل
التي ضربت تركيا وسوريا مصطفى العربيه
لندن